SPEAKER: With almost 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Using
Kubernetes, Spinnaker,
and Istio to Manage a
Multi-Cloud Environment,
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
As a business you don't
want to put all of your eggs
into one cloud basket,
so it makes sense
to choose a
multi-cloud strategy.
Or maybe your
developer and your boss
is telling you that you
have to go multi-cloud.
Either way, you're faced
with the challenges
of managing workloads and
resources across on premise
and multiple public clouds.
There are lots of benefits
to going multi-cloud.
You have the ability to optimize
based on cloud provider.
You have less lock-in
and better availability
in case of any downtime.
However, all of
these differences
means a complex environment with
diverse tools and capabilities.
Choice can lead to chaos,
and developers just
want the ability
to use a service.
Ideally, they can just
describe something they want,
and the resource
shows up for them.
Abstraction is
valuable to developers,
so we can walk through how
to make some of these tools,
develop and multi-cloud
approach to our application.
Let's demonstrate how to
manage container orchestration,
continuous integration and
deployment, and a service mesh
with this focus of abstraction.
It's also important
to note that you
can use any of your existing
tools and swap out for these.
These fit well for
multi-cloud, but you
can decide which are best
for your application.
Starting with
Kubernetes, you can
use this to coordinate your
containers in a consistent way.
This means that you get a
separate business logic, which
is the code that runs
the important stuff,
from having to manage
the services, which
is how it runs in the cloud.
This abstraction helps
you focus on describing
how the workload
should behave and scale
without needing to worry about
the platform or any hardware
specifics.
Once your application
can run, you'll
need to manage deployments
for releasing new versions.
Instead of pushing out a new
version to all of your users
at once, you can use a canary
build to release it out
to a limited number of users
and understand the impact.
In fact, there are a number
of ways to manage application
deployment.
Spinnaker gives you
application-centric controls
for all stages of the
application lifecycle.
You can create pipelines
to handle deployments,
rolling updates, version
tests, and do smooth rollbacks.
Spinnaker is open
source and works
with a variety of
extensions to fit
into your lifecycle
management and workflows.
Now that you've
got an application
running and updating smoothly
across multiple environments,
you need to make sure that
your business logic abstracted
from your network functionality.
Istio, another community-driven
open source effort,
helps you manage
your application
by doing exactly that.
This builds on the
theme from before--
give app developers more
time to focus on core logic
and abstract away all
the advanced networking.
By using Istio, you can
configure communication
between services, enforce
security and resiliency,
and monitor networking.
Istio is made up of configurable
components such as Envoy,
Pilot, Mixer, and Citadel.
It's a lot to take in, but
Ameer does a fantastic job
of showcasing what
these components do
and how they give you full
control of your application
networking for smarter
routing, higher
resiliency, strong
policy enforcement,
and observable metrics.
I definitely
recommend checking out
the walkthrough of Istio's
architecture for more details.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.